Donald Trump passait par la case prison
en Géorgie le milliardaire inculpé pour
avoir tenté de renverser le résultat de
la présidentielle américaine de 2020
s'est mise à disposition des autorités
sa photo d'identité judiciaire qu'on
appelle un atlantique a été diffusé et
c'est historique c'est la première photo
d'identité judiciaire d'un ancien
président américain immédiatement
reprises en une des principaux
quotidiens pour sa quatrième inculpation
6 mois Donald Trump n'a pu y échapper
convoqué par le tribunal d'Atlanta il a
passé ce matin une vingtaine de minutes
en détention avant de ressortir libre
après le paiement d'une caution de
200000 dollars il se pose en Marty
restait même empressé de poster la photo
judiciaire sur son compte x anciennement
Twitter avec ces quelques mots ne vous
rendez jamais en fait j'ai entendu
parler comme quoi il y a des implants
pour avoir testicules plus grosses
base ce que j'ai vendu à TF1 c'était une
spéciale testicule ils l'ont pas pris je
suis avec Ricky Eric un duo père et fils
on est tellement proche qu'on a un
troisième téton placé au même endroit
de problème pour me préparer à ce défi
j'ai déniché une plage naturiste au
Mexique pour éviter de débarquer ici
avec les fesses toutes blanches
bon on peut dire que les choses
sérieuses commencent
alors viens pas
je me demande sur qui je vais tomber ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça fait un bail
que j'ai pas vu de vagin voilà Rick sur
l'autre apaise
même si Eric vient de se prendre un
sacré coup sur l'entrejambe et Eric
triple téton passe à la deuxième partie
du parcours ça fait mal ouais j'imagine
[Musique]
ça va aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai l'opportunité de
partager ma dernière avec vous après
tant d'années autant vous dire que cette
musique
[Musique]
je l'ai entendu pendant 16 ans chaque
semaine évidemment ça va manquer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
merci beaucoup vous pouvez croiser ce
troisième panneau en tout cas en Afrique
du Sud
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
on vous emmène au Nicaragua regardez ces
images carnet rose ça va vous émouvoir
un petit Puma albinos vous voyez est né
donc il y a un mois habituellement le
pelage il est brun clair avec des
petites taches noires bon bah lui il a
décidé de sortir du lot on n'a pas
encore son nom mais tout ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il est protégé des visiteurs et
qu'il est en excellente santé pour
l'instant je sors je sors du spectacle
et là j'ai un message il y a marqué
Michel Drucker veut te voir
j'appelle Olivier je lui dis tu as lu le
message il me fait ouais il me fait
c'est peut-être pour le testament je
suis plus on va avoir un truc
on sait pas on sait pas peut-être qu'on
va récupérer le canapé il me dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
emporté par l'émotion la mère de famille
se lance dans un solo mémorable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le problème avec les pique-niques très
arrosé au bord de la rivière c'est que
ça peut vite dégénérer sur le moment
c'est très drôle mais quand il faudra
sortir la voiture de l'eau ce sera
peut-être un peu moins fun les gars
vous êtes encore là Michel mais je vais
vous expliquer le concept de la retraite
il faut la prendre vivant sinon ça sert
à rien
son ouvrage fait beaucoup parler depuis
sa sortie la semaine dernière nicolas
Sarkozy était à Ajax hier pour dédicacer
son livre de nombreux insulaires sont
venus à la rencontre de l'ancien chef de
l'État une séance perturbée par des
indépendantistes on écoute la réaction
de Nicolas Sarkozy
il y a 10 personnes énervées et mal
élevée qui ont essayé de perturber une
signature qui sont arrivés il y en a
plusieurs centaines qui ont fait la
queue pendant des heures pour que je
leur signe un livre le J concentrez
liquide d'ordures appelé savamment
lixivia le jus de poubelle
savez-vous que l'on pète en moyenne une
quinzaine de fois par jour mais pourquoi
tant de paix et bien on abrite dans
notre intestin des bactéries chargées
d'éliminer les déchets présents quand
elle digère ses déchets les bactéries
libèrent des gaz bref elle pète ces gaz
s'accumulent et descendent le long du
gros intestin pour arriver jusqu'à
l'anus et quand il y en a trop il faut
que ça sorte et c'est le P c'est la peau
située autour de l'anus qui vibre quand
on pète plus il y a de pression plus
c'est brillant un petit test pour savoir
si on sent bon la bouche on a un petit
peu de salive
on laisse sécher un petit peu en
attendant je vous que je vous raconte et
puis vous sentirez après si ça sent
mauvais bon c'est que vous sentez
mauvaise et donc
on peut péter jusqu'à 2 litres de gaz
par jour effectivement ça ne sent pas
toujours la rose les flatulences comme
les appels les médecins contiennent
notamment du sulfurdrogène connu pour
son odeur de pourri on trouve aussi dans
les pays du scatole un produit chimique
couramment utilisé en parfumerie car
s'il y a de fortes doses le scattle sont
très mauvais à petites doses ils sont
très bon
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]